can foreign policy gaffe still sink a
candidate Republican Presidential
hopeful Francis Suarez fumbling a little
bit after getting asked this question
about persecuted Muslims in China
will you be talking about the uyghurs in
your campaign
the uyghurs
what's a weird I look at what was it
would you call it a Weeble the wiggers
you really need to know about the
uyghurs mayor you got to talk about it
every day okay I will I will talk about
I will forward I will search uyghurs I'm
a good learner I'm a fast learner
Sora is trying to clean up his comments
like a champ by blaming the interviewer
quote of course I'm well aware of the
suffering of the uyghurs in China I
didn't recognize the pronunciation my
friend Hugh Hewitt used that's on me
but hey what's the big deal anyway Joe
Biden commits new foreign policy
blunders on a daily basis I mean he just
confused Ukraine with Iraq
has Vladimir Putin been weakened by
recent events it's hard to tell but he's
clearly losing the war in Iraq he's
losing the war at home and he is uh
become a bit of a fryer around the world
in the realm of gas Dana where does this
one fall for which one for Suarez Suarez
well when I saw it who was the first
person I texted you you did because I
was like okay do you remember Gary
Johnson in the 2016 campaign he was a
Libertarian candidate in the middle of
the Syria's uh and Isis beheading people
and he says what is Aleppo yes the thing
is what first of all if you're going to
go on Hugh Hewitt's show you better be
ready that is a tough show and he will
ask you about foreign policy and you
just have to have a staffer listen a few
days and to know that we might not be
ready for this yet boss maybe we should
hold off on this one for a moment
because even if he I actually don't
believe his answer I don't when he says
oh I didn't understand the pronunciation
no his response too is he writes
something like you would find on chat
GPT says China has a very bad human
rights record well yes of course you
Francis Suarez want to be president of
the United States you want to be the
commander-in-chief tell us why what is
your qualifications why would you be
better than Donald Trump Donald Trump's
foreign policy is in his interview with
Brett Baer was excellent so where where
are you going to be different where are
you better and blaming the interviewer
probably not a great idea and if he does
happen to make the debate stage I will
bet that he has a much better foreign
policy prep than he did talk about
uyghurs the entire debate yeah Greg was
this a
trick question or should he have known
the uyghurs Joe you know what I call you
you it
you would do it yeah that's pretty cool
um you know this is why you always have
to have these stock answers to stuff you
don't know about right it's like when
somebody's what about what how would you
about the uyghurs they go well we're
looking into it
it's very interesting
no but actually you wanna you wanna
glyco it's really interesting what's
happening right now but it's even more
interesting what we don't know and
that's what's scary is that we don't
know and can I just finish my last point
and then you go to the other point now
you're saying to me no no then you go to
the other point by the time you get to
that point Hugh Hewitt's already
forgotten that he's asked you about the
uyghurs in defense though that's you
Trump was good at this Trump would do
that we're looking into it yeah you know
we're looking into it that's what he
said but you gotta wonder how many
people that are giving him crap actually
knew
or care about the uyghurs we've been
talking about the uyghurs forever and
imagine how lucky politicians were
before TV and radio I mean what if
George Washington and Abe Lincoln were
Gaff machines and we just didn't know
pretty sure they didn't know about the
uyghurs you know so that's so it's like
you know you just have you're you're
doing more interviews you know you make
some mistakes just got to be prepared to
lie George Washington can't do that
though no yeah judge well you know I I
have to look at it because
I don't know uyghurs right I know what
they are we know what they are audiences
what they are but how do you spell
uyghur you spell uyghur uh the the
spelling is
u-y-g-h-u-r so maybe just maybe I mean
I'm not connected to him or anything
maybe he just read about the
u-y-g-h-u-r and he didn't know it the
way you pronounce it is not that it's
weaker do that again
you know what I'm not done yet that is a
better excuse than blaming who Okay
Hewitt it's very generous and it's a
good one that would have been better
yeah because if you read about it you
don't know how to say it I remember the
first time I heard someone say it and
then I went back to look at this
spelling because I had I never knew it
but you know what to me Biden stumbling
is the thing that I want to talk about
I'm shocked how how does this guy bite
by the way I'm his calling Ukraine Iraq
he did it at the fundraiser last night
he did it again this morning when he had
those lines on on from his CPAP machine
what I wanted you know we should be
happy the Xi Jinping doesn't return his
calls do you know how much trouble we'd
be in if this guy actually
a phone with a world a world leader I
mean really and he the guy is clueless
plus he can't breathe half the time you
know and maybe that's what it's all
about making fun of people for having
sleep apnea
came out what time did he get up if at
10 o'clock maybe he's still got the
lyric Adams breathing exercises
are sleep apnea patients another
protected class Jessica
so
I think that that was the most generous
thing I've heard about the uyghur mess
up and I think that when you don't have
good name ID you can't make mistakes
right Joe Biden
people have seen him make plenty of
mistakes no one really cares about this
it's baked into the proverbial cake
honestly what happens whatever Trump
says now has been baked in for years
right he can mess up on something and
people who like him
or impeach him I mean they indict him or
impeach them for real things not yeah
any hootles you can't make a mistake
like that because it will haunt you and
if you are going on Hugh Hewitt's show
and he who is someone who's not going to
you know be blindly defending Trump he's
open to the other candidates that are
out there you need to know that you're
going to be having substantive
conversations he's not going to want to
just talk about you know what's going on
at Disney and the groomers he's going to
be asking you about heart issues and I
didn't think it was a great moment for
him and people who are coming from jobs
where they don't have to deal with
foreign policy like this have more
ground to make up right he knows what's
going on I mean immigration is something
he obviously knows about by being the
mayor of Miami but you're going to have
to show that you have the chops for this
and I thought it was a meaningful fail
on that front but you make it it's an
interesting contrast that's a candidate
who knows more about what's going on in
our country
than what's going on in China and maybe
that's not so bad uh look I like mayor
Suarez I thought that he had probably
the most compelling launch video of any
candidate where he's running around
talking about his story is unbelievable
but you should know these things if
people if you're getting prepped and
it's on China this is one of the main
issues they have a million people in
work camps there all right how do you
spell uighur don't it starts with a u
well done
no start with a u H almost Greg we'll be
right back I want to Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now